[Musica]
[Applauso]
uno dei primi ricordi che ho da bambina
del mare e papà che si immerge nel blu
in quel momento il mio stato d'animo era
caratterizzato da un mix di paura e
curiosità col tempo la paura ha lasciato
spazio alla curiosità e quella che era
soltanto una passione è diventato il mio
lavoro
oggi sono una biologa e decollo kamarina
e mi occupo principalmente di studiare
come sta cambiando il nostro mare quelli
che sono gli effetti dei cambiamenti
climatici sul mar mediterraneo
avete mai sentito parlare di cambiamenti
climatici certamente sì ma spesso
pensiamo che sia qualcosa che non ci
appartiene lontano dal nostro presente
e invece fenomeni come l'acidificazione
oceanica avvengono tutti i giorni
proprio sotto i nostri occhi
la significazione oceanica è un fenomeno
dovuta all'assorbimento da parte
dell'oceano dell'anidride carbonica
presente in atmosfera e che noi
produciamo tramite le missioni delle
attività antropiche
questa causa un cambiamento nella
chimica dell'acqua e delle conseguenze
sugli organismi che lì vivono
dobbiamo infatti pensare che ad ogni
nostra azione corrisponde un effetto
sugli ecosistemi circostanti
vedete tutte queste bolle
queste sono bolle di anidride carbonica
e sono prodotte nei cosiddetti 20 i
venti sono dei sistemi molto particolari
sono dei sistemi che si formano in
diverse zone del mediterraneo e anche
oltre e che sono provocati da fenomeni
di dare a emissioni gassose dei fenomeni
di vulcanesimo secondario questo provoca
un abbassamento del ph e quindi da qui
il nome di acidificazione oceanica è un
cambiamento nella chimica del carbonio
per tale motivo tutti gli organismi che
costituiscono lo scheletro carbonatico
come molluschi e letino der mi sono
quelli più vulnerabili altre specie
invece come le piante
approfittano di questa anidride
carbonica in eccesso e si stanno
adattando a questi cambiamenti
i venti ricoprono un ruolo fondamentale
per lo studio di quello che avverrà nel
prossimo futuro e ischia in tal senso
ricopre un ruolo fondamentale infatti il
primo 20 è stato studiato proprio qui a
ischia e si trova sotto il castello
aragonese dove vediamo questa bellissima
prateria di posidonia oceanica
la posidonia oceanica è una pianta
marina
cresce rigogliosa assorbe l'anidride
carbonica in eccesso e gli organismi
calcare che normalmente si formano sulle
foglie sono fortemente diminuiti per
tale motivo la salpa che questo pes
erbivoro mangia tantissimo dalle foglie
di posidonia e la sua abbondanza risulta
raddoppiata ne fa nei 20 quindi nei siti
a ph acido rispetto ai siti a ph normale
vediamo quindi che la salva il pes ha un
vantaggio da un punto di vista trofico
la pianta la posidonia assieme agli
altri servizi eco sistemici che svolge
assorbe e limita la diffusione
dell'anidride carbonica
vediamo quindi come le specie si stanno
adattando a questi cambiamenti
io invece ho iniziato i miei studi
frequentando il liceo classico
ma mi sono accorto in corso d'opera
di non essere un umanista
la curiosità nei confronti della natura
tuttavia è una caratteristica in me
innata e mi ha spinto nel tempo a
studiare il mare a capirne le sue
interazioni i suoi processi e poi a
concentrarmi sul tema attuale dei
cambiamenti climatici in particolare
dell'acidificazione oceanica quando ero
al liceo una volta la prof di latino e
greco mi disse ma tu
che vuoi fare da grande io dissi io
voglio fare il ricercatore voglio fare
lo scienziato
e lei mi rispose ma la scienza e fredda
non ha anima non al logos
anche se
non sono romanista non mi piaceva tanto
lati nel greco qualcosa mi è rimasto
dello studio di queste lingue
soprattutto
per quanto riguarda l'etimologia delle
parole
la parola ecologia ad esempio ha un
significato molto denso molto importante
dal greco antico oikos
logos lo studio della casa il discorso
sulla casa ma di quale casa
l'ambiente che ci circondano e qual è
l'ambiente che ci circonda e il nostro
mar mediterraneo
un mare che è importante per molti
motivi
di cui uno anche un po personale perché
ospita i miei organismi preferiti che
sono le spugne marine
pensate che ce ne sono circa 700 specie
e
molte delle quali sono anche sconosciute
le potete vedere ce ne sono di tutte le
forme di tutti i colori
sono sia in superficie sia in profondità
distribuite in ogni dove nel
mediterraneo le spugne sono organismi
semplicissimi senza tessuti senza organi
sono fatte di silicio e di sponge na
essenzialmente di vetro e di collagene
ma proprio in questa loro semplicità c'e
la chiave per la sopravvivenza per la
resistenza anche ai fenomeni climatici
come l'acidificazione
ma come fanno
beh non è tutta farina del loro sacco
ma una grande mano gliela danno i
microbi che vivono dentro di loro
avete mai sentito parlare del microbioma
o del microbiota il più studiato e
quello umano oggi vediamo la pubblicità
in televisione che dice prendi
quell'alimento che ti si riequilibria il
microbioma ma anche tutti gli organismi
hanno dei propri microbioma che possono
essere investigati sé
facciamo delle analisi con delle
strumentazioni particolari come la
microscopia elettronica ad esempio se
guardiamo dentro una spugna possiamo
vedere tutti questi microbi contarli
analizzarli studiarli e e vedere quanto
sono importanti
i microbi all'interno delle spugne a
volte occupano anche il 50 per cento del
totale del peso dell'animale
e svolgono una serie di funzioni
fondamentali
aiutano a digerire il cibo
producono delle sostanze che allontanano
i predatori e soprattutto aiutano a
resistere alle variazioni ambientali
tra cui anche l'acidificazione oceanica
ma questo tutto questo per dire cosa che
la natura
l'ecologia il mare possono insegnarci
una cosa molto importante
e cioè che la cooperazione
l'unione sono la migliore strategia per
risolvere un problema
quindi se tutti facciamo un passo avanti
se tutti guardiamo nella stessa
direzione
riusciremo a trovare la strada giusta
anche per arginare il problema dei
cambiamenti climatici ma è importante
farlo adesso
perché il tempo
scorre veloce
per noi ecologi il tempo è un concetto
fondamentale
noi siamo storici della natura e abbiamo
bisogno di osservazione a lungo termine
per poter trovare delle risposte queste
osservazioni noi le facciamo lungo
l'asse del tempo
io ho frequentato il liceo classico e
non ero un umanista però una cosa l'ho
capita
e cioè che gli storici non possono
predire il futuro
per questo e per concludere vorrei che
tutti voi da stasera aveste una visione
più ecologica della realtà in termini
temporali
quindi riprendendo la linea del tempo
impariamo dal passato quando succede
qualcosa quando c'è una catastrofe
quando qualcosa mina il nostro ambiente
prendiamone nota
conserviamo le risorse nel presente
viviamo il presente per poterci
garantire il futuro grazie
[Applauso]